(swooshing)
- Practice.
- What's up Believe Nation.
Today we're going to
give you some motivation
so you can practice, practice, practice.
And as always, you know the drill,
if you hear something that
really resonates with you,
leave it down in the
comments, put quotes around it
so other people can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(dramatic string music)
- You look for
that thing that moves you.
I don't know what it is.
I like repetition.
There's a saying goes,
"Repetition keeps me green."
- [Charlie] Yeah.
- I love that saying, because--
- [Charlie] Repetition keeps me green.
- Keeps me green, fresh.
- Because the idea
that we do performances
over and over again,
you say, well doesn't
that get boring or stale,
but no!
It's in the repetition
that the creation comes,
that the expression comes.
Because, I'll give you an example.
I was doing Richard, once,
not particularly well,
and the show is going on,
and we couldn't get this court scene
with a lot of people in it.
I didn't understand what
I was doing in the scene.
So we would call rehearsals,
we'd rehearse it and stuff,
and we would talk about it,
think about it, you know,
like all this kind of
work were people together
are trying to figure out something.
The 85th performance of Richard,
my 85th entrance,
I knew the court scene.
I understood it.
I was there. I could play it.
- [Charlie] But not in 84.
- Not in 84.
I might have been getting
close and didn't realize it.
I gave up the ghost, I guess.
I just gave it up and said, "Oh, screw it.
"It's not going to happen.
I'll just keep going on."
And I found it.
- I remain uninterested in that topic.
- [Charlie] Which one?
The relation between gift and practice?
- No, I'm uninterested in natural gifts.
I know they exist and I know
there's such a thing as talent,
I just feel like...
And so what, right?
Because there are people,
and I always think of,
you're a basketball fan,
I always think of Derrick Coleman.
- Yes.
- I remember chatting with a
guy who worked for the Sixers,
and he said, "You have to understand
"that Derrick Coleman was
the most gifted man ever
"to set foot on a basketball court."
He said, "You've heard
a million other names,
"nobody was as good as Derrick."
And like, who has heard today, who thinks,
who puts Derrick Coleman
up there in the Pantheon?
No one.
He didn't want to work.
He had bad habits.
He had a bad attitude.
I mean, so what?
Give me somebody who wants to
go to practice in the morning
and who wants to try in games,
and I'll want to celebrate him.
- It wasn't until I started my own team
when I realized that there are people
with incredible talent and no motivation.
And then there are other people
that are willing to work their ass off
who don't have a natural ability,
but will become successful
because they're so determined.
And I saw it especially
in a couple of guys
that I first put on the Birdhouse team.
Namely, Andrew Reynolds, Matt Beach.
Matt Beach was, in my eyes,
the most naturally talented skateboarder
that I've ever seen.
Everything came easy to him,
and when I would request
these guys to go on tour,
all I ask of them is that they skate
for exhibitions and whatnot.
Matt wouldn't skate half the time.
I flew him to Europe,
I didn't have any money then
in our company,
but I was flying these guys
to Europe for competitions.
He would go to the contest
and not feel like skating.
And I was like, how can you do that?
Not just to me, but to yourself.
You have this incredible
talent and you just don't care.
And then I saw Andrew Reynolds,
who was this scrappy little guy,
not very clean in terms of his style,
but trying some of the hardest stuff,
taking the heaviest hits,
but always skating his
ass off and always trying,
and he has become probably
the most well-respected
street skater today.
Andrew Reynolds.
I mean, he formed Baker
Brand, Deathwish Skateboards,
the community of the most
hardcore skaters these days
call him the boss.
Because he developed his style.
Because he worked his ass off.
And he's the shining example of hard work.
- People have asked me
that over the years,
you know, how do I curl the
ball, or how do I bend the ball,
and it's something that just happened.
It's not something that
I thought, OK, I want to bend the ball
better than anyone else,
so I'm going to kick the
ball in this certain way.
I just worked on my striking of the ball.
I just practiced every day.
It's something that I've
done from a very young age.
Even after every training session
I take balls on my own
and just curl and kick
and try and find new ways of
getting the ball in the net
without anyone touching it,
and I've been lucky enough to
have done that over the years
with the way I kick the ball,
and I know that it's a unique style,
I know it's a unique style
just because my back hurts
a little bit more than it
did when I was 15 years old,
but no, it's something
I practice, of course,
that's one thing I tell kids.
Unless you practice,
you're never going to
get better at something.
- You have to practice over the years.
I wasn't great in the beginning.
I was aiight.
And then I got cool.
And then I got good.
Then I got better.
And then I got great.
Those are steps to becoming great
that a lot of people ain't willin
to take those steps.
It takes ten years at
something, continuously,
to become great at it.
And I stuck with it for ten years straight
before I had a record deal,
before I had money,
before I had lights and camera,
before I had, you know,
people wanting to sit
down and interview me.
- I need to practice.
Member before the day
comes, you got to practice.
You cannot be standing
at the free throw line
playing professional basketball
in the seventh game of
the NBA Championship
and hope right then you're
going to be practiced.
Practice is too late.
Larry Bird, the great basketball player,
he used to shoot, whatever,
a thousand free throws,
eight in the morning.
My friend Don Ravine
trains a lot of other
pro basketball players.
LeBron James, he trains.
He trains
Durant.
Kobe.
Chris Paul.
And he says, these guys are up
when everybody else is sleeping.
They're practicing.
So, everything you want is going to entail
a good bit of practice.
- I always believe that natural talent
can take you so far,
but I think you need
to have the work ethic
and the drive to achieve your potential.
I'd say my natural talent
probably brought me 50% of the way,
but then after that it was all down
to the work that I've done
and the volume of work that I've done
over the last 15 years
when I really started
to take golf seriously
and thought about making this a career.
- Whenever you talk about
ethics and integrity
in the Indian context,
the two companies that come to mind
are, one is Akartasans,
and the other is Wipro.
What is so special about
these two companies
that has been imbibed
in these organizations?
How is it done?
- Very simple, it's done by practice.
There's no other way you
imbibe things in an organize...
It is practice.
Integrity is practice,
leadership is practice,
innovation is practice,
it's all practice.
You've got to figure out what
you want your company to be
and what you consider
as non-compromisable,
not negotiable,
and then set those out and
keep them as simple as possible
and keep them as few as possible,
and practice them.
And practice them every day,
every hour, every minute
and have zero exception to them.
- The advice I give to any young kid
is, anyone can play a game of football.
Anyone.
But practice makes you a real footballer.
You see games in a Sunday,
pub games, oh, love a game of football.
The real players practice
after they go back home.
I remember being once in
Glasglow many, many years ago
and Gary Player was the guest--
- [Male Voice] The golfer?
- Yeah, the golfer.
And they asked him the question,
"Why do you keep practicin'
from the bunker?"
Because he was famous for the bunker.
He says, "Well, I know I'm
going to be in the bunker
"at one time in a game,
maybe twice in a game,
"and I've got to put in a hole.
"That's why I practice and
practice and practice."
That's a great example
of what you have to do
to be a top player.
- [Announcer] The Bulls
can win it right here.
The Bulls can win it.
Unbelievable! 13 seconds left.
Jordan, left side.
- I practice as if I'm playing in a game
so when the moment comes in the game,
it's not new to me.
That's the beauty of
the game of basketball.
That's the reason why you practice.
That's the effort.
So when you get to that moment,
you don't have to think.
Instinctively things happen.
- [Announcer] Jordan a try.
Aims. Fires. Scores!
The Bulls lead 87-86!
Michael Jordan with 45 points.
(cheering)
(dramatic piano music)
- I think it was a very defining moment
of what my career was in Chicago.
- [Announcer] The Chicago Bulls
have won their sixth NBA championship!
- [Announcer] And that's the last image
of Michael Jordan.
How magnificent is it.
- Thank you guys so much for watching.
I hope you enjoyed.
I love to know, what did you think?
What did you take from this?
Are you going to work harder?
Are you going to practice more?
Are you going to hustle more?
Leave in the comments below,
what was your favorite clip,
and what did you learn from it
that you're going to immediately
apply to your business
or life?
Leave it in the comments, I'm
going to join in the discussion.
I also want to give a quick
shoutout to Himanshu Premi,
thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book
Your One Word and making
that awesome YouTube video
around it as well.
I really really really
really appreciate it.
- I encourage everyone to read this book,
because this book has actually helped me
to find my one word,
and I'm 100% sure that it'll definitely
help you to find your one word.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you.
I hope you continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one word is.
Much love, I'll see you soon.
(swooshing)
- BB, do you still practice?
- Yes. Yes I do. Not nearly enough,
but I play every night practically,
at least four, five nights a week.
And I practice, but my practicin',
it's not what it should be.
Other words, to really just
get down and play the scales
and something once or twice a week.
But by me playing every night, usually,
I'm always running into something,
or accidentally falling into something
that I hadn't heard before,
then you go back and look for it later on.
- When you do practice,
what do you work on?
Do you have any specific exercise, or--
- My exercises usually, (guitar chord)
it's the scales, mostly.
(guitar scale)
Mostly that, then just all
over the neck of the guitar.
Because if I keep doing it, (guitar riff)
I usually will hear (guitar riff)
And you start to playing with a little
(guitar playing)
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- You know, you keep hearing,
and then you hear things
that you can play with.
- [Interviewer] Sure.
(guitar playing)
Yeah.
- You know, something like that.
- [Interviewer] That's
great. That's great.
- And that's what I keep doing until
my fingers say stop.